pornstars stormy Daniels answered yes
when asked during a polygraph test if
she had had vaginal intercourse with
Donald Trump yeah yeah the person who
administered the polygraph called her
answers truthful and disgusting in that
order
who wants to be even thinking about that
Donald Trump yeah I think he's grossed
out by the idea of him having sex this
is awful
it's come out to I mean now the whole
family is getting in on the act it's
come out that president's the
president's son Donald Trump jr. had an
affair with a contestant on Celebrity
Apprentice
yeah Trump jr. defended himself saying
have you seen Gary Busey's legs at
midnight
[Applause]
earlier today people talking about this
earlier today President Trump called
Vladimir Putin and congratulated him on
his presidential win yeah
coincidentally Trump made the same call
to Putin on November 9th 2016 so like
that's not when people laugh at you
could see everyone doing the math and
going yes it lines up it's not funny but
yeah he's getting kind of sad trying to
chat it but he does the dates work you
chose free that's called the shows free
applause we paid nothing for this show
we got what we paid for China China is
angry China is pressuring Washington not
to impose big tariffs on its steel yeah
and you can tell China's playing
hardball cuz today they said remember we
have your new iPhones I gotta win you
back I've got an hour ladies and
gentlemen and during that time I'm gonna
win you over one by one
you're gonna love this next joke I'm not
asking you I'm telling you here we go
get this a 102 year old woman broke a
pair of world track-and-field records
hundred - yeah the 102 year old ran the
100-meter dash with the time of February
that's how I win them back
on a 102 there is it uh there
isn't a spot in hell hot enough for me
according to a new study that just came
out and those are the best kind I'm
doing what I can out here according to a
study being a new mother is the
equivalent of working two-and-a-half
full time jobs it's the same the same as
working two and a half full-time job yes
yeah and even worse the boss is
constantly grabbing for your breasts all
the time it's the same thing
there's no need to act that out on Tara
now I feel like this is a hostile work
environment yeah I apologize
Ben afleck a lot of people talk about
Ben Affleck Ben Affleck's getting teased
online after a recent photo revealed
that he has a giant back tattoo you may
have seen this take a look there it is
it's a giant Phoenix that covers his
entire back now the tattoo has gotten a
lot of negative feedback there's one
person who has come out to support the
tattoo check out this new tattoo that
his friend Matt Damon just got he's
showing his support that's going to wear
well over time I think
you